người dân hả nội tắt nập đi mua hát et này của cùng trong năm.
Các trợ chuyện thống trên nhiều tuyện đường như là lòng quân khoảng khoảng khoảng khoảng khoảng khoảng
có thể điểm uống tác, so lượng người đủ về, tiêm mua kê cạnh hòa tết với sáng yêu đại hơn.
Mình thấy là mình mua rất là đẹp và tình lỗi là dẹp, mọi một năm mới đưa cạnh đào về ra đi mình
cũng chính là đưa một sôn về đến với ra đi.
Mọi rất đông buổi và thấp nập.
Nếu kế ngày này nhiều khi đi ra đưa mình này lại cái xúc thuy tý rất là nhiều,
mấy hôm một dốt chương phục phí nhiều đông nhưng mà tụng qua đến hôm nay là phục phí nhiều lắm.
Tụng phí là khóc là giảm giá này, ra là gặp ra còn những khóc tươi này mình vẫn thấy như vậy này.
Hóa rất là nhiều, ra có thể mình sẽ mua được cái giá hợp lý hơn, và cái tư tiền của mình.
Mấy tụi lần người muốn đến 1 bòng nè, quý này quý lòng thì mình mới gái gì đó, nó hết để bệnh.
Mà muốn được thị trọng.